la russie de nouveau pointé du doigt par
le royaume uni de munich râble ministre
des affaires étrangères britannique a
accusé des hackers d'avoir interféré
dans les élections législatives
britanniques de 2002 9
il affirme être presque certains de ces
opérations proviennent des
renseignements russes écoutez nous
sommes maintenant en mesure de dire que
nous pensons savoir avec une confiance
raisonnable que les acteurs russes ont
été impliqués dans des tentatives d'
interférer avec les élections de 2010 9
principalement en essayant de diffuser
d'amplifier en ligne des documents
divulgués obtenues illégalement relation
avec des négociations de libre-échange
entre le royaume uni et les etats unis
une enquête pénale est en cours je ne
peux donc pas en dire plus il est
important d'attendre l'attribution
spécifique mais nous nous réservons le
droit de prendre des mesures appropriées
lorsque nous aurons la conclusion de
cette enquête à une accusation sans
fondement pour maria zakharova la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe qui
demandent des preuves
le gouvernement du royaume uni a déclaré
par le biais de son ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur rab qu'il
ne voyait rien qui indiquerait que je
cite la russie soit intervenu de manière
flagrante dans les élections
législatives de 2010 9
monsieur rap dénonce en revanche toute
tentative d'ingérence comme intolérable
en outre des informations circulent sur
une enquête criminelle
une enquête est en cours a indiqué rab
il ne convient pas à ce stade que nous
fassions d'autres observations à ce
sujet vidéo de ces déclarations sont
formulées dans des termes tellement
vagues et sont tellement contradictoires
qu'elles deviennent pratiquement
incompréhensible s'il ne convient pas
d'en parler à leur nom par l'epa si vous
en parlez alors fournissez des éléments
de preuve
nagai technique qui est ce légal et au
pdl a réussi également accusé par le
royaume-uni les etats-unis et le canada
de l'espionnage médical les trois pays
affirme qu'un groupe de 'hackers' liés
au renseignement russes attendait d'eux
robes et des informations sur des
vaccins contre le coc big 19
il indique qu'il s'agit selon leurs
recherches du groupe a pété 29 qui est
également accusé d'avoir interpellé
interférer dans la présidentielle
américaine de 2000 16 la russie unie
toutes ces et négation le porte-parole
de la présidence dimitri peskov dit ne
disposer d'aucune information au sujet
de ce fait autant ciel akers